so do you look at Ashton and think about
maybe when you were starting out what do
you mean down the business looking at
him thinking of what kind of memories
does that bring back for you well you
know we all actor in Halloween we we he
asked a lot of questions that I that I
might have been one of the few people
that could answer that have been down
the road that he was he's heading down
so so and and just just my nature you
know he became like a son to me you know
so you know always kicking up yeah why
do you say questions that you wanted a
few people who can answer because I'm
one of the few people that get it as
relates to the business or being in my
position and things like that
in particularly race not in particular
to that no but that's a part of it too
yeah do you is it you think it's easier
to navigate now than maybe it was when
you were starting out like how's the
business change per se I don't keep tabs
yeah you know has it been a black studio
agent Sony's gotten close to cup oh yeah
so what he did I think they got close a
couple times but no there hasn't been
yet mm-hmm
[Music]
well you know getting close was not
getting it past you so yeah you got a
ways to go but it's so it's interesting
I spoke to Melissa and she said you know
when denzel's on set you know being the
actor that he is he's in mode and it's a
very serious set and then Ashton was
like said something very similar he was
like my mentor we got to talk joke
around it was great maybe you can tell
us on the two ends of the spectrum where
does Denzel fog does he fall on both
here's the thing 99% of the time I'm
behaving in in the way that has to do
with the scene I'm about to do so some
days people might say man he's the
nicest guy in the world in other days
they might say man he won't talk to
anybody I'm about to work I'm not there
that you know I'm about to work while
I'm there we didn't we can go out and
have about a burger afterwards but if
Thor in the case of me and the young boy
the relationship helped
me getting to know him better and
wanting to get to know him better and
him having questions for me and all that
bled right on it that that was felt
seamless bleeding into the he's a young
boy wants to know about life well like
the movie there's a context of the story
where he's in between a rock and a hard
place getting involve a street life
versus actually pursuing art as someone
who grew up you know earning Mount
Vernon in New York I could tell him
something about that
yeah could you relate to that yes you
did yeah soo-ji what was the difference
maker for you in terms of choosing your
path and I get killed well go to prison
really yeah that's the difference most
of my partners got murdered or with the
prison for long stretches so I didn't is
there any kind of coming out on the
other side of that is there any kind of
social responsibility or any any kind of
thing you feel or affinity towards
people go through similar struggles some
of them deserve what they got you know I
just did get caught what are you doing
about this franchise this is the second
installment it seems like we could
possibly see another one we'll do the
public who tell us that we'll see what
happens in the next the next month well
no a month from now won't we that's
what's your great phone though Thanks
thank you